[Music]
right now I'm standing in a particularly
depressing part of Van Nuys California
that was never repaired after the war
this is the legendary iron head studio
that's right iron head studio where they
make many of the costumes for giant
franchise superhero films films that
make billions and billions of dollars in
profit we're gonna go inside and meet
the geniuses that make these costumes
we're gonna find out how they do it why
they do it
who does it when they do it eliminate
those last two the building just farted
that's how shitty it is here but they're
geniuses inside let's go check it out
[Music]
this is Jose Fernandez Jose really cool
to meet you Sam you did the most recent
ben affleck man you probably measured
every inch of his body
[Music]
it's amazing the minute you put this on
your whole attitude changes I would
demand to be seated first in a
restaurant gal gadot let's talk about
that for a second she was on my show
stunning
such a stunning very nice but my god is
gal gadot beautiful
yeah good god she's gonna think about
her for a little bit I can pull this up
in editing I just want to think about
gal gadot what are you thinking about of
course that's the iconic Batman helmet
you did sort of wonder when I was
watching the movie why doesn't suit man
just use his heat vision to burn his
mouth Wow there's this is I think Sumner
Redstone I love this right here I called
this me before coffee and then that's me
after coffee
immediate transformation and then of
course I'm recognizing Matt Damon yeah
and there's Ben Affleck right there yeah
Ian McKellen you jack around you
oh this Hugh Jackman yeah if you Jackman
walked in and he saw that those other
actors were placed up there he was
shoved on top of the old stereo receiver
it'd be bad you mind if I
we do it well he's just pretending that
this isn't happening this is Wonder
Woman this is actually her body yeah
this is act replication of gal gadot is
her body and then we repositioned it for
promotions there's anyone here ever put
the Matt Damon head in the other room on
to this just a perv out oh my god
gender I think is becoming more and more
fluid this is an amazing statement
[Music]
I have come to Jose because I want to
have a superhero costume made for me I
would like it to be sexy and appealing
to women feel free to get in there and
examine what do you think don't I
you definitely have small calves I think
mine are bigger than yours yes I'm
imagining that with some actors you
enhance a certain region down south some
of you had some you minimize I would
like that to be enhanced enhanced almost
to the point of like the movie couldn't
be released this is important because
I've always heard women do not care at
all but the size of that area it's
completely irrelevant to their
attraction to the man and that's just a
man's fixation but women actually prefer
a much smaller penis it's what I've
often been told
so one area that we haven't brought up
is that I have no ass what I'm saying is
that there's just nothing what are you
doing you think this is helping me why
does it always have to be haha look at
the Freak what do we do to begin start
with the body scan and measurements
[Music]
[Applause]
and this is for one I may inevitably
scared and defeated
[Music]
[Applause]
city take it away
[Music]
you